now it's your turn to write some media
queries you'll be using dev tools to
make some changes to this page inside
the elements pane open up the head there
you'll find a style tag and inside the
style tag you've got some breakpoints
set up for you and it's here within the
style tag that I want you to make your
changes simply right-click and do edit
as HTML and you'll be able to change it
apply style so that between 0 and 400
pixels the background color changes to
red and then between 401 and 599 pixels
the background should be green and if
the page is 600 pixels or wider make the
background blue when you've set the
right breakpoints you will see a code on
the screen type it in here to continue
and by the way you might find it's
easier to actually write your code in a
regular code editor like sublime text
and then paste it in here